spécialiste we say factices elles non
plus caché enfin si vous savez pas qui
c'est il connaît pas quelque chose
n'allait pas mais la france entière que
les quêtes chou n'a pas moi et on va
voir vous allez voir vous allez que
marié lui ravissant les ravissantes pas
vraiment c'est a alors dormi j'ai
entendu parler d'elle à une personne
revient cache où on était pas la météo
non elle fait la pluie et le beau temps
mais ne fait pas la météo cash ou ne
m'appelez plus jamais caste ou quoi or
on peut plus vous appelez garçons c'est
pas vrai ça c'est les journaux qui ont
écrit ça j'ai jamais dis ne m'appelez
plus quelque chose renie pas ce que j'ai
fait oui j'ai un fort juste que mon vrai
nom cinq chars sans abri est gelée
repris possession la demande quand même
temps pour à votre avis pour passer de
quechua anne charlotte pontabry parce
que l'euro ça va prendre trois ans je
crois j'ai beaucoup de mal moi aussi
mais je sais pas toute façon les gens
choix ils peuvent continuer à m'appeler
quelque chose s'ils préfèrent alors
qu'elle joue c'est ainsi un surnom que
vous avez donné votre votre père quand
vous avez une jaunisse oui en fait non
oui c'est pas si c'est vraiment il sa
fille rubi non je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment la raison
dans tous les cas c'est vrai que je suis
né avec la jeunesse comme certains
enfants vous êtes né avec le soleil mais
ça arrive je ne sais c'est parti mais
donc voilà oui effectivement
voilà alors le papa de quel show ces qui
le papa de cachou bas c'est le monsieur
qui vivait avec la maman d'ophélie
monsieur qui vivait avec la maman de
faits david ericsson non non non non pas
du tout c'est pas ça non c'est à
monsieur s'énoncer c'est votre papa y
disait que la maman de pays après après
david alexandre winter c'est ça je vais
compliqué à c'est très compliqué il faut
lire voici assidûment faut prendre des
notes et que j'aurai pas toutes ces
fiches abaissement on est content j
arriverai pas que je la vérité vous
pouvez poser des questions et katchoo
son numéro de téléphone tout ya passé
une hyper nous ont peu à peu près tout
demander quand ils osent paris match
elle est tétanisée pour le parti de jeu
j'ai décidé d'être très calme à profiter
de votre talent alors le mot ici on peut
poser des questions de principe de
l'hyper viewsonic a mis une interview on
est deux une hyper nous on est quatre à
quatre sur france 2 à quatre macaques
sont mauvais alors katchou vous êtes en
ce moment sur scène au bataclan dans
megalopolis c'est ça jusqu'au 30 avril
ça marche oui ça se passe très bien avec
francis lalanne qu'on a reçu les
ressentis ses missions qui a été été
formidable en garde un bon souvenir de
francis dahlab il nous a insultés que
deux fois à bon honnêtement on était on
était obligés aussi très content aussi
alors génial à mesa maize et des forges
j'aime beaucoup mais oui alors attention
non vraiment il chante bien
ils sont très bien formés mais qui
tapissent difficile peut pas être
foncièrement mauvais c'est mieux que ce
score a atteint 1 avec 8 go sport
d'hiver aux saisies mon papa beaucoup
mais qui alors megalopolis c'est une
comédie musicale engagé c'est un peu les
hippies charruel quoi c'est un monde un
peu comme ça un peu comme le meilleur
des mondes
et vous vous êtes avec l'aller puis
toute une bande vous êtes un peu des
révoltés contre ça c'est ça oui en fait
l'espace en 2020 et herbert pagani a
écrit cette la musique à 1,72 et c'était
vraiment très visionnaire ce que c'est
vrai que ça il a vu en 72 qui arrivent
petit à petit dans notre société quoi et
c'est vrai qu'on lutte contre ce succès
cette société de comics de consommation
et on est toute une bande de jeunes
comme ça et leur pas gagné il avait
écrit effectivement en 72 il avait
chanté tout seul à chaillot 1
et puis ailleurs je sais pas où est
ensuite le malheureux est mort je savais
pas moi vous savez quoi
faites gaffe mais la seule à les faire
chanter tout ça il était tout seul
chantez vous voyez rien n'y faisait
plusieurs personnages vous êtes 14 14
pour un truc tout simple et seniors
alors n'était pas gagné pagani avait vu
juste et vous vous chanter juste alors
ce qui a vraiment dans tous les articles
qui a eu sur megalopolis tout le monde a
dit elle chante juste comme s'il y avait
des doutes
un mois mais vous chantez très très bien
paraît-il gentil maintenant c'est vrai
c'est ce que alors quand vous jouiez
dans les séries pour m6 et c est ce que
vous jouiez aussi juste que ce que vous
chantez juste maintenant je pense que
j'ai fait des progrès depuis mes débuts
déjà tant que comédienne puis c'était un
sitcom donc c'était ont joué très très
vite on n'est pas vraiment le temps pour
travailler nos scènes et tout ça donc on
jouait comme ça quoi donc je pense que
depuis j'ai fait des progrès vous les
regardez des fois les sitcoms de m6 on
va regarder un petit bout
j'ai prise
sacré raphaël mais pourquoi il m'a c'est
un truc pareil tu sais pour la tienne sa
portée sur mandat bons sentiments moi
c'est autre chose
je crois qu'il est complètement mardi
non faut que j'y aille je vais rappeler
au cours des 36 me bon allez je me sauve
car elle vient de déclarer à l'époque
les critiques m'ont fait souffrir
je me demande s'il ne vaut pas mieux
être moche vieille et sans talent vous
pensiez à clients 10 ans alors je pense
à personne
non mais non je pensais à personne ce
qu'on m'a beaucoup traité de jolis
petits potiche et tout ça donc j'aurais
été je sais pas moi moi je revienne
vallauris je peux vous dire alors vous
allez nous avait quittés aussi toutes
ces séries de m6 en disant je ne voulais
pas rester collé à vanessa demouy toute
ma vie parce que ce qu'il faut dire
effectivement c'est les actualités chez
moi ce n'était pas assez pas comme telle
avec avec ophélie winter elles étaient
soeurs de l'e sour donnait cher de l'est
et à vanessa demouy la maman de vanessa
dirige l agence de mannequins s'appelle
duties où étaient en charge note donc
elles étaient ensemble déjà dans l'
agence ensuite elles étaient ensemble
dans les domiciles dans les sitcoms
voilà moi je connais pas tout ça je
trace tous ont passé la sienne il doit l
année les garçons il était alors n'y
était pas
c'est déjà ça on peut pas tout faire non
plus dites moi justement je vais vous
demander vous avez donc elle est devenue
quoi vanessa demouy
je sais pas vous êtes vraiment pu coller
avec el alaoui et mallory la dynastie
mallaury nataf
ah je sais pas non plus des amicales
aubry a d'ailleurs dit qu'à ça c'est mon
ami en revanche pas en parler parce que
toujours collé année on est très amis
elle très fait beaucoup d'émissions sur
mcm l'alcool en tant qu'animatrice
elles vont bien mais vous êtes celle qui
s'en est mieux sorti quand même mais
véronique ascenseur très bien vous et
rencontrer tous les rushes et arthur
vrai sur les tables oui vous avez toutes
les deux de 30 et toutes les deux sur
les tables à karaoké comme des folles
oui et ça ça prouve déjà si la recherche
sûre qu'elles savent lire parce qu'il
faut et on sait pas lire du fonds
on a juste une très bonne oreille qui on
a une mémoire et des dix ans mais mali
ok d'arthur c'est gênant parce qu'on
l'ait prise comme chanteuse à ses
formidables parce que moi à côté j'ai
les jambes dans une casserole
c'est vrai qu'on pouvait revenir et avec
les casseroles et casseroles et des
changes il ya c'est vrai une action de
grâce à frites dedans vous êtes vous
êtes déjà que rencontrer la b2 et vous
en êtes perçu comme une casserole mais
je peux te dire par là que nous avons
est ressorti tout on les dit non mais
voilà comment on a fait un petit par
hambourg - avants mégalo parce qu'une
feuille pour sa mère manon jérôme gêné
donc c'est un jeu vous avez entre vous
ça numéros tirés des prêts mario et il
est roi
alors avant megalopolis j'ai déjà essayé
de chanter sans ça on n'est pas obligé
d'en parler donc on va regarder le bape
ne va pas regarder chez lidl en ce
moment il fait tout ce temps mais elle
n'est pas crois que j'ai vu à quel
silence aussi producteur de 10
les fat chanteuse morphine s'inscire est
fait chou blanc comme d'assassinât il ya
quatre ans déjà d'un modèle choisi par
winston plus elle il n'est pas nouvelle
plus fort
en tout cas elle va être hyper jalouse
ophélie ta demi soeur mais arrête de
dire rien dis moi on m'a dit enfin wayne
existe des gens qui m'ont dit qu'elles
allaient mal le prendre
très très très belle est beaucoup plus
mince vraiment à bout et c'est pas du
tout pareil
oui c'est pas glee les gens
applaudissent
oui parce qu'on leur a dit d'applaudir
twitter maintenant ils ont applaudi
spontanément alors maintenant on va
passer aux choses sérieuses
1 quand on sait que lui tous les deux
c'était crédible c'est très sérieux
parce que quand j'ai connu quelques
soucis c'est vrai vous étiez fiancée
avec un jeune avocat dont je dirais pas
le prénom parce que je suis un jeune
avocat j'ai dit non mais s'il a les
cheveux teints en noir
alors il vous m'aviez dit à l'époque
pour vous devez parler un vrai coup de
foudre pour ce garçon dont je ne vis pas
le nom toute façon parce qu'en fait
cette réflexion ça c'est mieux
vous vous connais vous connaissiez
dollar connard non pas collard j'ai dit
un vrai garçon classe m non ne dirait
pas son nom des jeunes farce end oui je
ne sais pas les beaux un jeune homme
regarde je promis à cacher ou ne pas
dire son nom d'accords sarkozien alors
vous m'aviez dit cachou vous m'aviez dit
qu'à l'époque vous vous étiez ensemble
vous connaissiez déjà depuis deux ans et
quand vous êtes sortis ensemble c'est
parce qu'on appelle un coup de foudre
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais en
revanche ni janvier un vrai coup de
foudre et on va voir pour qui maniait
tôt
ce soit mon qu'on dirait vente c'est
pour quand nancy que mr sans chlore
te
un hommage au penseur
sont venus
lors de son long faire sourire sommet
pied je pense du mézou
sita
at war un
genre de jeu
celui qui fera l'amour
e
celui là on dit parlant on du mal dans
sa vie passée puis pas le nom pour la
dernière fois de la dernière émission
m'avait montré une fille aussi qui était
avec un même mec qui chantait la même
chanson annoncé le ranger mais laurent
gerra c'est l'original alors les gars ou
c'est ça non mais vous convient pas non
feinte c'est marrant ça faisait d'une
indiscrétion comme l'a reconnu amnon ben
nicolas ce qui s'est passé non mais ce
qu'on peut dire je n'en peux dire
qu'elle je ne sais que quand vous êtes
allé voir le spectacle
et quand vous l'avez vu sans sa bosse
dans les commissions mais c'est la
vérité c'est moche vérité rien d'autre
en vue de les vendre à la vérité du jour
n'est pas non mais c'est quand vous
l'avez vu dans les coulisses sans sa
bosse au buffet qui étaient organisés
dans les coulisses vous allez vous avez
eu un coup de foudre
non mais c'est pas grave lara fabian
elle dit bien calé avec l'autre à
comment il s'appelle a theory fiori
n'attendait pas grand temps qu'un appui
de l'ibla je me rend si yahia laquelle
il ya bruno pelletier est libre donc
c'est à un appel que nous lançons à
toutes les françaises et notamment
chanteur patrick fiori et en prix garou
et en prix bruno pelletier main cet
appel me servait à rien la mission
initiale des herbiers garde jeune le
franc alors taper les gargouilles
il reste général dont l'abeille reste on
peut dire son nom
bon je crois je vais arrêter de vous
torturer là parce que j'avais l'air
dans la dernière c'est surtout vous une
dernière question ici quand on s'est
connus vous faisiez 90 63 90 aujourd'hui
vous fait combien je ne sais pas je me
dira pas tous les ans sans faute de la
gymnastique avec des cassettes de cindy
chronique j'arrête et maintenant je
viens dans un club de gym
ah bon et vous savez pas combien vous
mesurez banon vous savez combien vous
mesurez vous du tout ça m'est rendu
bonbek à chaud je vais arrêter de vous
torturer parce que on a été discret
reconnaissez la suite